si je suis bon les gens vont pouvoir
s'intéresser au livre et si je suis pas
bon les gens ne vont pas s'intéresser au
livre et toute cette pression m'a été
transmise pour mon moniteur qui m'a dit
tu as vraiment intérêt à être
bon j'ai choisi une archive où je suis
particulièrement concerné puisque c'est
ma première apparition à la télévision
c'était l'émission de Bernard R qui
s'appelait caractère et je venais de
sortir les fourmis et cette émission est
d'Ant plus importante pour moi c'est
elle qui a lancé toute ma carrière
Bernard verber je vous inviter bien que
vous soyez un petit peu hors du sujet
parce que dans les fourmis publié chez
Albin Michel vous nous brossez le
portrait d'une société absolument idéale
ou presque idéale le monde des des
fourmis précisément une société qui elle
a traversé va traverser les siècles avec
une incroyable capacité d'adaptation un
sujet sur lequel on verra ça tout à
l'heure vous êtes absolument àollable je
suis sû vous avez des fourmilières chez
vous ou oui tout à fait j'étais mort de
peur durant toute l'émission on é éta
plusieurs invités je croison était 5 il
y avait Alvin toffleur j'avais mon petit
écouteur dès le début de l'émission
Bernard r nous a dit voilà l'émission va
durer 1 heure et vous avez droit à
chacun 10 minutes j'étais le dernier
tous ceux qui débordaient de leur temps
et tous essayer de déborder de leur
temps en fait il prenaient ce mon temps
à moi vu que j'étais le dernier j'ai
vaguement conscience de ça mais Bernard
rap
aussi connectés ils ont une chance ou
ouais très court très court faut laisser
la place un pe peu au four formidable
faut quandême qu'on en parle fait oui
oui j'ai beaucoup apprécié non on a
souvent tendance al fait cour en même
temps c'était quand même ce que
j'attendais le plus c'està-dire un
moment où j'allais pouvoir enfin
présenter mon travail Bernard verber est
un fou passionné des fourmis vousêes
vous êtes vous vous connaissez toutes
ces animaux là oui un moment je me suis
intéressé à ça donc un moment seulement
12 ans vous avez quel âge j'ai 29 ans
vous avez commencé à quel âge 17 ans
vous y intéressez aujourd'hui j'ai
commencé d'abord par mettre comme tous
les enfants par terre et puis je voyais
que ça bougeait il se passait quelque
chose extraordinaire je sais pas ce que
c'était la réaction normale c'est donc
les écrasé moi je suis resté à regarder
j'ai mis 12 ans à l'écrire tout ça pour
arriver à cet instant précis où si je
suis bon les gens vont pouvoir
s'intéresser au livre et si je suis pas
bon les gens ne vont pas s'intéresser au
livre et toute cette pression m'a été
transmise par mon éditeur qui m'a dit tu
as vraiment intérêt à être bon donc
pression énorme énorme énorme et votre
grand rêve à vous c'est dans le 2 2500
ou 3000 ou 10000 je sais pas Bernard r
me dit une phrase que dans mon souvenir
ça serait est-ce que vous croyez que les
hommes et les fourmis un jour c'est que
l'homme fasse à l'UR avec la fourmi on
sait pas qui sera la bête de qui mais
c'est c'est ça votre idée dans ma tête
c'est je lu demande de répéter ou pas et
ça me semblait un peu inconvenant de
demander de répéter donc je dis oui en
me disant j'en sais rien ou ça serait
vraiment un mode
extraordinaire pourquoi pas ouais
c'était totale panique à ce moment-là
j'ai le système de communication qui est
très intéressant parce que justement on
retrouve c'est dans la chimie C ce
coupci il y a un autre intervenant qui
arrive et qui se dit ben c'est
l'occasion de d'en placacer une mais on
retrouve des processus qui sont assez
proches de ce qu'on commence à voir se
développer lorsque l'émission est
terminée j'ai l'impression que j'ai pas
pu dire grandchose celui qui m'a
interrompu il sort un
chronomètre et il avait la main en
permanence dans la poche et il montre à
son attaché de presse le temps qu'il a
pris et là un coup je prends conscience
qu'on était en train de se battre pour
du temps et que lui il a gagné parce
qu'il m'a pris du temps sur mon temps de
parole voilà merci à vendredi prochain
je suis parti c'est je surtout j'étais
obnbilé par cette question que j'avais
pas compris j'avais échoué le lendemain
mon éditeur m'a appelé pour me dire que
tous les libraires commandaient le livre
et que une cine réimpression j'ai
compris que la règle du jeu était
différente de tout ce que je croyais
quand on fait une mauvaise prestation ça
intrigue mon éditeur il m'a dit en fait
en effet on sentait que tu étais pas à
l'aise on sentait que Bernard voulait
t'aider mais que le système était
difficile on sentait que tu étais timide
et du coup tu étais touchant c'est ta
maladresse et le fait que tu n'arrives
pas à t'imposer qui t'a rendu
sympathique et c'est pour ça que les
gens ont dû vouloir voir le livre du jeu
c'est d'être authentique je dois
beaucoup à cette émission beaucoup
beaucoup